hello oh this incredible woman uh Wang
odd she is a Filipino tattoo artist and
she is on the cover of Vogue as you can
see and at 106 year old so it's this
year's April issue of Vogue she was the
oldest person to Grace the cover she has
been tattooing since she was 16 so she's
been doing it for 90 years that's crazy
people travel to vanilla at Manila and
then go on a car ride for 12 hours in
order to get tattooed by her and she
passes this tradition on to younger
women in her generation that's really
amazing so if someone who's 106 can do
that and I'm like thinking I'm tired I
don't know I'm running out of time what
do how do I get things done that was a
great story so I started researching
other people who are in their 90s and
100 and seeing all the different things
that they do so here are some of their
stories starting with a local Dorothy
Lathan she lives in San Francisco has
been in Ocean Beach for uh since the
1960s she keeps black history alive in
the city and was part of creating the
Museum of African diaspora the moad and
she was also one of the first black
school teachers Jack Kern he is a judo
sensei in Great Britain at 99 he just
recently got us his 10th Dawn which is
the highest belt that you can get for
um for Judo and that's makes him the
oldest person who's ever done that and
he moves every single day she is the
highest paid living female artist today
she lives in a psychiatric hospital by
choice in Tokyo and every day she walks
across the street to our art studio so
she can paint and actually create pieces
and she does this consistently it's
amazing Iris Apple she is an interior
decorator by trade has worked for nine
U.S presidents but really catapulted to
success and she was 84 and did a solo
show at the Met and she is now a model
Muse influencer she is oh something
jumped I've done awesome David
Attenborough what a living treasure he's
fantastic he has created over 100
documentaries created the Natural
History documentary as you know it today
with beautiful cinematography
photography fee and he has also won a
bafta and we go on to DJ sumirak she
runs a dumpling shop by day and is a DJ
by night she DJs and Shinjuku regularly
has also DJ'd in Paris and New Zealand
has dreams of DJing in New York and
that's her and her dumpling shop that
she's she's been doing for some 60 some
years and she was in high school she
started DJing when she was in her early
80s and it's continued and that is just
fantastic I want to go see her I hope
everyone else does too Baddie Winkle
she's one of my favorites she lost her
husband and her son and was kind of in a
slump and then her granddaughter posted
a photo of her on Instagram and she
became super popular because she wears
vibrant clothes is kind of um really
really loud and out there and I was also
like a like an influencer like
officially an influencer I love that her
bio says it's really hard to see it says
stealing you're a man since 1928. it's
really really great I mean what a hero
I hope we can all be a little bit like
her and embrace that energy uh Dr Howard
Tucker he is the world's oldest
currently practicing doctor he's a
neurologist and he actually says
retirement is bad for cognitive
um cognitive ability it actually
decreases uh your your mind it actually
slows you down and here one of my
favorites uh my grandmother she moved
into a retirement community seven years
ago and instead of just slowing down and
doing nothing she started teaching
poetry to the other members of the
community and she wrote a book on poetry
her university did a documentary on her
it became super popular actually she's
on TV interviews she went viral in China
she came became known as poetry grandma
and got 150 million views it's really
it's really spectacular she kind of just
like well I'm just working hard and
doing the thing so it's I'm very happy
to be with her
so many great lessons overall keep
moving your body keep using your brain
keep learning keep being curious it's
never too late to start anything so many
examples they started very very late in
life think of yourself as young and stay
connected with your community
ending with Julia hurricane Hawkins who
started running when she was 100 years
old and it's the current record holder
for the her age group at the 100 meter
sprint and I love her quote I feel like
a shooting star and I don't know when
it's going to end well I'm so great
thank you everybody
foreign